they are playing their first
round draft pick Zack Benson
he's 18 years old Joe and there's
the chance and E to start comes up
in Little Drop pass and ends up on the on the
Buffalo stick of Jeff Skinner there's the draw
pass and then Mikan just over skated it you're
chasing the game yeah Minnesota lost seven in a
row and so coaching made coaching change happened
uh this afternoon nice play by Zack Jones keeps
it in and shoot save made by luuka pekanin
they never found their game at all Miller shot
stopped by pekanin fourth line again for the
Rangers Trouba moves it up for BC it's by him
y Haru is able to move it to Owen power power is
bumped on the play and the Pu taken away by Tyler
pitlick taken back by Payton Krebs now kyoso to
Krebs KBS moves in and shoots Z by shurkin tough
shot Ryder sent it across and played it in the
Buffalo Zone Eric Johnson former number one pick
overall that's intercepted by
Johnson up ahead in Middle stat Rangers take it
back wheeler sending it to Eric Guston with buck
the chance in front the save by S on Alex Tuckers
rang have turned the puck over numerous times
here's another one and this is a topnotch chance
by Alex tuck Skinner behind the net to tuck in
front benino gets to the red line leading kie kie
Cuts in his shot was blocked he gets the rebound
a save made by pekcan got it to Zan Jad that was
broken up by Eric Johnson in front Eric gson P
Aon K off the glove save by pinin the Rangers just
clean up that part of their game they should be in
good shot good couple only had 12 total shots in
their loss New Jersey on Saturday but kept in by
Owen power blocked in front of it score JJ [Music]
[Applause] PKA Buffalo Sabers finding ways and PKA
in their Zone and gson tries to make the pass
does over to uh his his partner and then great
just couldn't get the puck out of their own the
attempted pass there goes right on the stick of
power and so misfire on the pass by Ryan lingren
an awful lot of Promise 21 years old a native of
Germany in a second round draph pi in 2020 as Alex
tuck coming in GL save just thk showing you the
numbers on JJ peterka long shot from the point by
Yoki Haru got through able to clear the Zone uh a
competitive player for the Bruins they find him
the maximum amount the lean shoots and the save
by shesterkin Buffalo getting some good shots
midd that with a shot to his block PKA plays it
rink wide back the other way save just stking on
B they just high quality chances the Savers are
getting olon his pass broken up cleared out race
for the puck Panera there save rebound save by
panin but if you give them a little a little room
and space and time you can see they can make plays
here's CER moving in with his shot save by Lucan
rebound save Lucan BRS it through to Panera for TR
and it's save by [Music] Lucan around the boards
panan under a minute to go in the first period
uh no Sam just checking I wasn't one of the 10
zillion people at Sabers move in a big Save On
Oposo Again Rangers aren't sharp in this
one but shurin is CH was on for the faceof
he goes off as I mentioned Rangers dominant on
faceoffs in the game here's tuck puts it out in
front and the shot went wide on the boards
delen F petka save Sher rebound score Alex
Tu and the Sabers have a two nothing
lead in front the net middle stamp with one
shot there's the sa but then the rebound and
Tuck gets to it as tuck is a big guy
and he had position on Keandre Miller
VY getting it to gusterson now wheeler with the
pass and V he sh have save L had got his stick
on it unbelievable and was going an empty net had
the whole net now here's the setup from wheeler
and watch the net wide open net and lucanet just
wouldn't give up on the play diving save with the
shaft of his stick and it just trickled past the
far post and Jimmy VC could not believe it Owen
power off his stick Jimmy VC trying to find it
power pass across Z just stking on a tough shot
rebound loose the shot didn't get through body's
falling everywhere power play's over this is big
Power Play Chance Rangers they're thirdd of the
game over for two he wins another one gust A J
scores mik is the power play goal look how he
battles to win this face off now the Rangers
have control couple of quick passes and that
one was hammered just inside the post Guston
puts a in the perfect spot for Zan Jad and he got
everything on that one now 440 to go in the third
two to one Buffalo leading it long pass ahead
for Middle staff he bumped with Miller pass in
the middle tuck shoots he scores Alex tuck
ripped the wrist shot over Igor shuring to
give Buffalo the two goal lead again it's three
to one one yeah this this was a a one-on-one now
Buffalo starts with power just throws it down the
boards and then here's the play middle stat and
Miller and middle stat makes the play against
Miller and gets it to tuck who just rips it
home whoa laier set up in front off the
cornerboards to crder then it's taken
away and brought out by Skinner he gets it
to Middle that who puts it into the empty
deck Rangers had the puck in the offensive
zone but couldn't get any shots Joe no they
just kept done they kept passing and around
and the puck to the net and eventually the
pressure by Buffalo they make the they make the
play Skinner makes the play on the board middle
stat is at a strong game for Buffalo Joe and I
will be back with you Saturday afternoon from
Nashville on the air at 4:00 with Rangers
game night the Sab score on a sharp angle
shot by Kyle Oposo he has goals in three
straight games that was a fabulous pass
from Yoki Haru who is back in the line up well
a disappointing finish Rangers certainly will
have some concern for Capo kako who was
injured Rangers head off beaten 4 to one